pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
bonjour les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux que doit-on dire sabrer ou sablé
le champagne
les deux mon capitaine puisque ces deux
expressions ne signifie pas la même
chose
allez je me fait mousser
l'expression sabrer le champagne a vu le
jour sur les champs de bataille pour
fêter la victoire
les hussards de la garde napoléonienne
buvait du champagne qu'il débouche n ont
pas à la main comme vous et moi mais en
utilisant leur sabre un coup sec en
faisant glisser le revers de la lame du
flanc de la bouteille vers le bourg aidé
par la pression qui règne à l'intérieur
l'eau boulot le bouchon et nous museler
sont violemment éjecté sabler le
champagne n'a rien à voir l'expression
signifie le boire d'un trait par
analogie à un geste pratiques et en
métallurgie l'industrie des métaux le
métal en fusion et versé d'une traite
dans un moule en sable aujourd'hui on
utilise cette expression pour signifier
qu'il va couler à flot lors d'une fête
même si vous le savez avec l'alcool il
ne faut pas pousser le bouchon trop loin
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]